[Applause]
okay we've been drinking a little bit
the whole time hey can i ask you by the
way where can i get your wine we're in
like grocery stores all across the
country
you can walk down your grocery aisle can
i say that you can go to drink
aveline.com of course and we have a
bottle locator on our site you just put
in your zip code we'll tell you where
the look the closest bottle of avalene
is to you we're just there you guys
we're just waiting for you to enjoy
and
if you go to the drewberrymore show.com
we're going to show you right how to get
over to the aveline site and get your
glass and get a drink thank you all
right now it's almost time to go but we
love to leave you with a little
something to take on the road it's a
tradition for us and it's called the
doggie bag
[Applause]
and today it's an la institution denim
doctors on beverly boulevard they can
make your favorite jeans last forever
they do alterations and repairs and they
can even turn your favorite jeans into
maternity jeans with elastic bands hey
and you don't have to be in la you can
send your jeans to the denim doctors
from wherever you are so
take a look um so you know this is
goodbye
and um i just want to thank
you so much auntie poopoo
otherwise known as cameron diaz
um to everyone else on the planet but
thanks poops love you love you so much
[Applause]
and we'll see you again real soon
[Music]
you